you know what else i do so i
i'm sort of notorious for putting grape
seed oil on my face all the time like to
obviously
combat aging
um i'm fine with that but also i'm
fighting it tooth and nail but
i also put in my mouth ew mmm grapeseed
oil if you before you go to bed because
my mouth gets dry in the middle of the
night right yeah i just put grapeseed
oil on my teeth my gums in my mouth no
one else does this no olive oil i mean
on pumpkin
but if you have a dry mouth situation
now i think i might try it yeah because
but when you're on the road yeah like i
always am then you get you get dry mouth
in a random hyatt in toledo you're not
finding a biotene spray no no so i'll
just take a swig of olive oil that's so
and it stays and you wake up the next
morning your mouth
no one
like no one's nailed moisturizing the
mouth yet no they haven't actually
but wait when you say putting the olive
oil that sounds like those people who do
that oil pulling have you heard of that
you go like you swish no one's heard of
that i've heard of that keep going well
but that's basically i wanted somebody
else to have heard of it because that's
all i know is that they switch and it
just sounds disgusting like oil pulling
it's an alternative medical practice in
which an edible oil is swished around in
the mouth for a period of time and then
spat out similar to mouthwash and
practitioners of oil pulling claim it is
capable of improving oil i'm sorry
improving oral
improving oral and whole body health
that is like um to me
on the level of premium sunning butthole
stunning that's like it's there's easier
ways to do it and if you're
swishing around oil in your mouth and
you're
oil pulling and telling me about it
you're just trying to be better than me
like i just you have too much time on
your hands um
but wait the the
perennium stunning i thought people
wanted to bleach it now it's getting it
tanned well here's the thing
just i guess
like i feel like i'm behind on
everything it was literally and
figuratively
so
yes i my first anal bleaching experience
happened in las vegas wait you did it i
did well i unclear i can't see it i
don't know will someone tell me to have
my asshole bleach i would
bend over i'd spread out and make sure
that thing got blue well here's the
thing if you're gonna bleach your
butthole you also have to laser it off
because if you have a bleach butthole
with brown
hairs coming out it's not gonna
there's like they should do like a
one-two punch situation where it's like
you get bleached and waxed because if
you bleach it but don't wax it it's
still gonna have a you know yeah it's
not gonna be as pink as you
would have imagined so i go to i'm in
vegas this is like 14 years ago
yeah probably and it's the first time
anyone ever reached out to me to give me
something for free no the first thing
you got for free
no bleaching as like a person who's on
tv it was like hey like would you like
to come in for a free thing like the
first paid partnership i ever had i just
got a first paid partnership for a
vibrator
they said we're emily fans and we'd like
to send you a video for me